is going to use the notebook to take out
all of the world's criminals so that
only the good remain he wants to create
a new world a Utopia with no bad people
or crime this approach is popular and
light or as he becomes known K amasses
followers all over the world who realize
that someone is dishing out punishment
to criminals and supports his Endeavor
others see him as just as bad or worse
than those he is killing and seek to
hunt down and arrest this new serial kod
the debate in the series has extended to
real life with fans arguing over whether
light was a good guy or a bad guy
non-stop in the years since the series
came out as a fan I spent a lot of time
thinking about this series so it's easy
for me to see that while light has good
intentions it is evil for any one man to
be judge jury and executioner the legal
system has split up these roles for a
reason having one person handle all
three is too much power and that leads
to corruption which is exactly what
happens to life one person's judgment
can never be unbiased and may not always
be fair